The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DENNIS FREEMAN:
Hello, and welcome.
So like last time, the
important announcement
is of course that we
have an exam coming up.
So exam 2, Wednesday,
everything's
very similar, analogous to
last time, with the exception
that we are in Walker.
Don't go to Building 26.
Go to Walker.
Other than that things look
very similar to before.
The idea will be
that the exam will
focus on things since exam 1.
However, this subject
builds on itself.
So the official coverage is
1 the 12, lectures 1 to 12,
recitations 1 to 12,
and homeworks 1 to 7.
Questions?
Comments?
All the logistical
issues are clear?
AUDIENCE: I had one question.
[INAUDIBLE] how much do we
have to know about [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: So there was
an introduction to root locus.
Sorry, so everybody
knows what root locus is?
You can find out after class.
You know, it will just making
me feel a lot better if you
nod your head yes.
Root locus is the way
you figure out the locus
of possible points that
a pole could move to.
There is an enormous number
of rules for thinking
about how root locuses evolve.
And if you're really good
signals and systems person,
you know 50 rules.
That's not the
point of this class.
You should know that poles move
around when there is feedback.
We'll have examples of
that in class today.
You should be able to
calculate how they move around
for simple problems.
You're not expected
to know the rules.
OK, so you shouldn't be
surprised by the rules.
If we ask you to derive one of
the rules, you probably could.
But we don't expect that
you've memorized the rules.
Does that sounds
roughly correct?
OK, other questions or comments?
Content, administration,
anything like that?
OK, so about a week
ago, Russ introduced
the idea of using feedback for
the purpose of controlling.
And the example in lecture
was controlling a robot.
You've seen that before.
Right?
That's 6.01.
And then in recitation
yesterday, he
ran over some more
ways of thinking
about more sophisticated ways
to do control with feedback.
And the point of those
more sophisticated ways
to do control is
really performance.
The idea is to
enhance performance.
And that's the theme that
I want to build on today,
today and on Tuesday.
How do you enhance
performance by using feedback?
And we'll go through
a number of examples.
You can use feedback to
increase speed and bandwidth.
You can use feedback to change
the control variable from--
I'll do an example--
speed to position.
You can reduce distortion,
reduce sensitivity
to parameter variation.
You can stabilize
unstable systems.
We'll do a bunch of examples.
The point is that
you can use feedback
to accomplish a lot
of different tasks
that generally speaking
improve performance.
So with that, let me
think about an op-amp.
You all know about
op-amps, right?
That's also a 6.01
sort of thing.
So an ideal op-amp would
have a bunch of properties
that we would like.
We'd like it to have--
it we'd like it to
be very high speed.
We'd like it to have a
very broad bandwidth.
We'd like it to be fast.
We'd like it to have a very low
output impedance so it works
like a perfect voltage source.
We like it have a very
high input impedance so
that when we hook
it up to something
it doesn't change the something
that we hooked it up to.
There's lots of things
we'd like it to have.
Unfortunately, it's difficult
to build a circuit that
has all of those things.
And so here is an
example of that.
Here's one of the world's most
popular op-amps, the LM741,
invented eons ago
and still used today.
The idea that's plotted here
is the frequency response.
You remember frequency response.
What's the frequency
response of an LM741?
Well, if you plot as a
function of frequency,
how does the gain change?
Well, the gain is enormous.
High gain, that's what
we'd like it to have.
The gain is enormous
at low frequencies,
at 1 radian per second.
But the gain becomes very
small out at high speeds
at the speeds we think we
think about when we're thinking
about communication systems
or when we're thinking
about computation or things.
When we think about speeds
that are electronic speeds,
the gain is actually
pretty small.
Similarly, the phase changes.
The phase of very low
frequencies is near 0.
That's kind of ideal.
0 would mean in phase.
The output reliably tells
you what's the input doing.
So that's good.
But as you go to
higher frequencies,
you start to pick up
a phase delay, which
means the output is telling
you what the input did
a little while ago.
OK, that's less good.
So the performance in terms
of providing a lot of gain
is quite good for
some frequencies,
but not for others.
Unfortunately, the range
where it's not very good
is most of the range.
So if you thought about
an op-amp doing even
a very low frequency problem,
like audio signal processing,
most of the frequencies that
are of interest to audio
are in the region where the
op-amp is not working too well.
We hear sounds from about 20
Hertz to about 20 kilohertz.
And that range is
indicated by the red arrow.
And you can see that's not where
the op-amp is working ideally.
Similarly, we would like
the op-amp to be fast.
Fast is indicated
here by thinking
about the step response.
So if you thought about having
an ideal step at the input,
what would the output look like?
Well, we'd like it
to be an ideal step,
but it generally isn't.
Generally, there's some lag.
That's associated
with that phase delay
that I talked about.
And in fact, what
I'd like you to do
is figure out exactly how it's
associated with that phase
delay.
Think about-- so figure
out-- it will turn out
that the step response
can be characterized
by a time constant tau.
The time constant tau is the
time required for the signal
to get within 1 over e of
this final value determined
from this.
I've already told you the
performance parameters
in terms of frequency.
You should be able to
use 6.003 to figure out
what that implies about time.
So look at your neighbor--
OK, look, look, look.
And now, figure
out which answer--
what's tau for the 741 op-amp?
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
OK, it's dead quiet.
So I assume that
means convergence.
So what's the answer?
What's the time
constant tau of the 741?
Raise your hand with a
number between 1 and 5.
Don't look at other people,
just raise your hand.
OK, I can see a couple
of answers I don't like.
How do I think about
converting this representation
to that representation?
What should I do first?
Shout.
I start with the
thing on the right.
What should I do next?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] of like
doing a 2 over tau or something
like that?
DENNIS FREEMAN: So we're
looking for something like e
to the minus t over tau.
That's right.
We're looking for
something like that.
How do I get that starting
with the thing on the right?
AUDIENCE: It's like using poles.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Poles,
what a good idea.
How do I figure out poles
from the thing on the right?
6.003, poles, that
should be like hard wire.
Right?
So when you hear the word 003,
you should think the word pole.
How do you associate a pole?
Can somebody tell me what the
poles of the right-hand system
should look like?
AUDIENCE: Where the line is.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Where the line
is-- there's a couple of lines
there.
AUDIENCE: The vertical line.
DENNIS FREEMAN:
The vertical line--
how many poles are on the right?
How many poles are in
the system represented
by the right-hand figure?
AUDIENCE: One.
DENNIS FREEMAN: One.
How many zeros?
Zero, wonderful.
So we have to think about
a pole, just one pole.
So we think about the s-plane.
Right?
Where's the pole?
You already told me.
AUDIENCE: 80 halves,
so it was 40.
DENNIS FREEMAN: 40--
OK, where's 40 over here?
Somewhere in there.
Got it.
Where's the pole over here?
It's at location 40.
That's actually
correct, well, sort of.
Negative 40, that's
exactly correct.
So negative 40, so the
pole is right here.
OK, so the pole is at minus
40 radians per second.
How do you know that?
Well, that's that Bode stuff
we talked about last time.
Right?
So if the pole were here, you
would think about a vector.
So this is the j omega axis.
Right?
You would think about a
vector connecting the pole
to some location on
the j omega axis.
If the location is omega small,
it's going to have some--
that vector is going to
have some length like that.
It's going to have
an angle of 0.
And as frequency
goes up, the vector
gets longer, which means that
the magnitude gets smaller
because poles and bottom.
Right?
And the phase goes
increasingly toward pi over 2.
But it's in the bottom.
So it's minus pi over 2.
Right, so the frequency at
which you get to pi over 4--
OK, 0pi over 2-- the frequency
at which you get to pi over 4
is--
so pi over 4 is here.
Right?
So the distance here,
the critical frequency,
the frequency at which the phase
is pi over 4, minus pi over 4,
is going to be the same as
the frequency of the pole.
So that's how we know
it's at minus 40.
Right?
So we know that this then
is a characterization
of that system.
It's not quite done.
So what's the h of
s for this system?
If I've got a pole at minus
40, what's h of s look like?
Shout, shout.
These answers coming up,
this is perfect practice.
AUDIENCE: I've already
talked too much.
DENNIS FREEMAN: What's
h of s look like?
AUDIENCE: Is this
something over s plus 40.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Exactly,
What would you like
the something to be?
We'd like it to be some k.
We'd actually like it to
be related, for example,
to the open-loop gain.
How big is the gain when
frequencies go towards 0?
What's the gain at 0?
Let's say the gain of 0--
let's define the gain of 0, k0,
let's define the
gain at 0 to be--
so what is the gain at 0?
10 to the 5, 2
times 10 to the 5.
Right?
It's a little bit above
the 10 to the 5 line.
OK, so now if I define
k0 to be that gain at 0,
what's the numerator over here?
If the numerator
over here were 1,
what would be the
low-frequency gain?
1 over 40, right?
To think about frequency,
we think about 1
over j omega plus 40.
Right?
You substitute s equals j
omega to think about frequency.
And if omega is very
small, you get 1 over 40.
Right?
So if you wanted that to be
1, you'd have to make it 40.
But we don't want it to be 1.
We want it to k0.
So you'd want it to be 40 k0.
Or to be a little
bit more general,
we'd like this to be of
the form alpha k0 divided
by s plus alpha.
Right?
So now, we've got the
Laplace transform.
We can figure out
the time response.
What's the time
response associated
with that Laplace transform?
You remember the impulse
response of a system
is related to the system
function via the Laplace
transform.
Right?
So all we need to do is
take the inverse Laplace
transform of that thing.
And we get h of t.
So what's h of t?
OK, it's such a strain,
all those weeks ago.
e to the minus t, e to
the minus something t.
So we need something
like e to the minus what?
Alpha.
e to the M alpha t u of t.
And there's going to be that--
that thing is going
to come out here too.
And it's going to be like that.
And then if you wanted
to find the step response
what would you do?
h of t is the impulse response.
How would you find
the step response?
A step is related to the
impulse by integrating.
The step response is related
to the impulse response
by, surprisingly, integrating.
So you would
integrate that thing,
and you would end
up with something.
Right?
So you would get
something like k0 1 minus
e to the minus alpha t u
of t, something like that.
I think that's right.
OK, the time constant
is given by alpha.
Right?
So what is the
time constant now?
1 over 40, right?
So it's alpha t.
But the time constant
is t over tau.
So the time constant is
the inverse of frequency.
Right?
Frequency is per second.
Time constant is seconds.
They're reciprocals
of each other.
OK, so the idea then is that we
can associate a time response
with that.
And that time response
is pretty slow.
A 40th of a second, 40
things per second kind of.
That's my speed.
Right, that's not
computation speed.
Right?
So that's pretty slow.
So we'd like to improve that.
And one way that
we can improve it
is by thinking about feedback.
So the idea would be we
don't use the op-amp just out
of the package the way it comes.
We put it in a feedback loop.
So for example, here
you could put it
into a non-inverting
amplifier where
you take the output divided
by a voltage divider
and feed that back in.
In 6.003, the way
we'll think about that
is that the effectiveness
plus and minus
input is to take the
difference between two signals.
Right, we're going to
take a circuit diagram
and turn it into a integrator,
gain-adder diagram, a block
diagram.
We're going to take
a circuit and turn it
into a block diagram.
So the way we think about
the plus and minus input
of the op-amp is
as a subtractor.
And then this k of s that
characterized-- so this thing,
right, this thing here, we
plug-in there just as a box.
And the effect of the resistors
is to divide the output signal
by some constant beta.
So we can reduce the circuit
to a 6.003 equivalent.
And then we can use
Black's equation
and all those other things
that we do in 6.003.
So we can write an expression
for the closed-loop system
the looks like k of s
over 1 plus beta k of s.
Make sense?
So then, as we've already
seen, the op-amp by itself
looks like a pole at minus 40.
So we can substitute
this expression
into that expression
for the closed loop.
And we get a new closed loop.
So h of s, which had been alpha
k0 over s plus alpha becomes--
the new value is alpha k0 over
s plus alpha plus alpha beta k0.
OK, so the point is that
we can think about the way
the feedback changes
the system function
by just formulating what's
the circuit look like in terms
of a 6.003 block diagram.
So now, the effect of that, it
looks as though what happens
is the pole went
from here to here.
How big of a change is that?
What's the biggest change in the
position of the pole that you
can achieve using feedback?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] distance.
DENNIS FREEMAN: I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: [? Is ?] [? beta
?] the [INAUDIBLE] distance.
Or where are they located?
DENNIS FREEMAN: I want a
factor by which you multiply
alpha to find the
biggest place that you
could have put the new pole.
I didn't say that right.
I want to know where
is the new pole.
Sorry, I confused myself.
Where is the new pole?
How left can you put the new--
how left can you get
the new pole to be?
What's the furtherest--
left is good, right?
Left is good.
Everybody knows that, right?
So right is bad.
So small distances
in the s-plane
correspond to slow responses.
Big distances correspond
to fast responses.
That's what we saw in part one.
So we're trying to push the
pole that way as far as we can.
How far can we get it to go?
OK, everybody raise your hands.
The answer is-- and again,
I see lots of answers
that I don't quite like.
With a minor perturbation, all
those people who I don't like
can become right by saying--
so a lot of people have said
this, which I don't quite like.
What's the biggest distance
that I can move it?
OK, new vote--
I didn't like tw0.
And so therefore, I will
change my answer to four.
Wrong, no.
How big can beta be?
What's the biggest
possible value of beta?
One.
So how far can I
push it to the left?
So I can push it this far.
Right?
So if I make beta 1,
that's as far as it goes.
Beta 0 is kind of the
rightmost position.
Beta 1 is the leftmost position.
I can get it that high.
But that's very good.
Right?
1 plus k0-- k0 is a
number like 10 to the 5th.
So I can get at like 10 to
the 5th bigger than it was.
That's enormous.
That means that I can stretch
the frequency response.
If the pole is the thing
that determines the frequency
response by that
construction up there,
I can stretch the frequency
response by 10 to the 5th.
That's huge.
Pure win, right?
Well, that doesn't sound right.
So I've stretched the region
where the gain is constant.
I've stretched the region
where the phase is close to 0.
It's a 100% win except
that I've cheated
when I drew the plot because I
normalized it by the DC gain.
DC, I probably didn't
define that yet.
DC is direct current.
It has nothing to do
with current or direct.
DC means zero frequency.
I have no idea why we insist
on using that word, but we do.
DC means zero frequency.
OK, so you just do that
automatic mapping in your head.
Every time I say DC,
I mean zero frequency.
Everybody else
talks that way too.
So the DC gain, I've divided
the magnitude by the DC gain,
h of j0.
So this is the relative
frequency magnitude,
h of j omega, divided by the
magnitude at omega equals 0.
Had I not done that, the picture
would have looked different.
If you think about
what happens--
so the top curve here shows
what happens when the--
shows the response curve for
a 741 op-amp with no feedback.
It has a pole at 40.
It has a pole at minus 40
to be a little more correct.
So there's a single
pole at minus 40.
That corresponds to beta 0.
That's open loop, no feedback.
OK, and what you can
see is the DC gain
is 2 times 10 to the 5th.
And there's an AC gain defined
by the cutoff frequency.
If you compare this expression
and that expression,
the interesting
thing that happens
is that the DC response
depends critically on beta.
But the high-frequency asymptote
doesn't depend on beta at all.
The high-frequency asymptote
of this is alpha k0 over s.
They're the same
high-frequency asymptote.
What happened was that as
I increased the feedback,
I lopped off the
low-frequency gain,
which had the effect of
making the frequency look
like it got very big.
So pure win?
No.
Almost pure win?
Yes.
OK, I've traded-- the trick is
I've traded gain for bandwidth.
That's important
because the folks
who know how to
microfabricate things
know how to make things
with very high gain.
Making things that
are fast is harder.
This is a way that
we can take advantage
of the relative simplicity of
making things with high gain
to make them behave as
though they're fast.
OK, you can see the
same thing if you think
about the response in time.
If you think about
the response in time,
we're going to go from e
to the minus alpha t to--
I guess I didn't write it down.
It's going to be e
to the minus alpha 1
plus alpha beta
k0 t, same factor.
It's going to get 10 to
the 5th times faster.
Again, it looks like pure win.
But that's because I've
cheated because I'm
plotting via this
normalized final value that
depends on beta.
If beta were 0, the final
value is 2 times 10 the 5th.
If beta is anything else,
the final value is smaller.
If I plot it not
normalized, you get
a kind of different picture.
So if you were to use
the op-amp open loop,
the response has a time
constant of 1 over 40,
as we said before.
If you include feedback, it
decreases the final value,
but has the property that it
does not change this slope.
So if you think about this,
this is an analytic expression
for the closed-loop
step response.
I get that by integrating
one of these expressions.
I didn't write
the beta one down.
I need the beta
equivalent one of these.
If you right the
beta equivalent one
of these, which is on a previous
slide, and integrate it, you
you get this expression.
And the if you differentiate
this expression with regard
to time to find the
slope, the slope at 0
is unchanged by beta because the
exponent here, 1 plus beta k0,
has the same form as
the denominator here.
So when you differentiate
it, this comes down.
The two cancel.
And you end up with a slope
that is independent of beta.
The effect of that is that if
you change the final value,
it appears to go much faster.
So pure win?
No.
Apparent win?
Yes.
We've traded gain for speed.
OK, so that's ways that
we can use feedback
to improve the
performance of an op-amp.
OK, the big
performance parameters
that I talked about today
were bandwidth and speed.
You could do the
same kind of analysis
with many different
kinds of metrics
for op-amps like output
impedance, input impedance,
distortion reduction.
We'll do distortion next time.
| there's lots of other
things that feedback improves.
I've illustrated it with two.
In both of those, as will be
the case in all of the others,
the effective feedback
is to trade gain
for something else of interest.
OK, the next example
I want to think about
is thinking about
a motor controller
where what I want
to think about is
changing the way we think about
the input-output relationship.
So I take a motor.
That's my motor.
And what I want to do is
have it control position.
So it's not too easy to
see probably because it's
such a tiny little motor.
Actually, it's not
a tiny little motor.
It's an enormous motor.
So the red bar,
that's the shaft.
Right?
And so the first question I
want to think about is what's
the relationship for the motor?
What's the relationship
for the motor
for the transformation from
voltage to angle of the shaft?
So what's the relation
between v of t and theta
of t for DC motor?
This is very much
the same problem
you worked in in the
head-turning problem in 6.01.
So you should be able to
remember this answer from 6.01.
What's the relationship
between the voltage into a DC
motor and the angle out?
Is it one, two, three,
four, or none of the above?
Talk to your neighbor.
Figure out the right answer.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
So what's the answer-- one,
two, three, four, or none
of the above?
Everybody votes.
You're on such a streak.
More than half the answers,
I really don't like.
OK, so we'll do a demo,
and we'll figure out.
So the question is,
what is the relationship
between voltage and speed?
So I've got a
motor, and I've got
a knob that controls the
voltage that goes to the motor.
OK, so now, I turn the
motor on, and nothing
happens because I preset
the voltage to be 0.
Now, I turn the
voltage to the right
to make the voltage
a bit positive,
more positive, back towards 0,
at 0, negative, more negative.
OK, so what's the relationship
between voltage and angle?
AUDIENCE: Is that
velocity or voltage?
DENNIS FREEMAN: v
is voltage, sorry.
v is voltage.
Theta is angle.
So here's 0.
Here's 90.
Here's 0, pi over 2, pi.
Right?
The question is,
what's the relationship
between the voltage
input of the motor
and the angle of the
shaft the output?
And now, the answer is--
OK, the number correct
has not changed.
So tell me in words-- forget
the one, two, three, four--
what's the relationship
between voltage and angle?
What is [INAUDIBLE]
of the voltage?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN:
Angular velocity.
So how do I get
angular velocity?
AUDIENCE: [? Measure
?] of the angle.
DENNIS FREEMAN: So I'm giving
you the angle, theta of t.
How do I get angular velocity?
AUDIENCE: Derivative of
the angle-- the derivative.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Take
the derivative, yes.
So what I want is that theta
dot proportional to v. OK?
Which of those
relationships say that?
None of them.
OK, it was a trick
question of course.
So what do I want to have as
my model for the DC motor?
I want my model to take a
voltage in and give me theta
out.
What should be in the model?
k, it's always good
to throw a k in.
That always works.
Excellent answer.
k always works, sure.
In any physical system,
you never get one, right?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: You're going
to need an integrator, exactly
right.
So it's going to
need something like I
think I call it a gamma, a
being the accumulator guy.
Right?
A different way of
saying that would be--
or I write it in
terms of Laplace
transforms, I would
get gamma over s.
So if I put v in, and I
want to get theta out,
right, I need to put it
through an integrator.
So the idea is that if I put
a constant voltage in-- say
the voltage is 0--
theta was flat.
But if I put a voltage
at the blue line,
theta increased at some rate.
And if I changed it to
red, it increased faster
just like an
integrator would do.
So what I want to do is
think about the motor
being an integrator.
OK, that lets me then
cast the motor, which
is a physical thing,
into 6.003 terms again.
So now, I can think
about the problem.
I'd really like it not
to be a speed controller.
I'd really like it to be
a position controller.
So feedback to the rescue--
what I'll do is I'll
put it in a loop.
So the idea is
going to be that I
take my motor, which looks
like an integrator, gamma a,
feedback a signal that's
proportional to the angle,
which I derive by having
a potentiometer strapped
to the back of the shaft--
so there's a pot.
I've taken off the little
stop so that it spins around
doesn't hit the stop.
Right?
Otherwise, it would be kind
of bad for the first part
of the demo.
So it's a surgically
altered potentiometer
that spins around forever.
But over most of the range,
it's reporting angle.
So that's the way I get
this feedback loop in.
And then I put it
into this thing,
which is really
just a 741 wired up
like I showed in
the first example,
so that it would take the
difference between two
things, the desired input, which
is a potentiometer that I'm
turning here, and the
actual position, which
is the potentiometer up here,
the same kind of potentiometer,
just one that I turn, the
other that the motor turns.
And the op-amp figures
out the difference,
multiplies it by a gain, alpha,
and presents it to the motor.
That's the idea.
And if you just think about 003,
it's pretty easy to see that
you can represent this
relationship by a single pole.
Right, there's some
annoying constants.
Right, you have to worry about
the gain of the amplifier,
the gain of the motor,
and how much feedback.
That's alpha, beta, gamma.
But pretty much,
it's just a pole.
So what happens then
as you change the gain?
Well, if the gain
is 0, the pole--
so if the gain, beta,
is 0, the pole is at 0.
OK, it works just
like an integrator.
That's what we said before.
That's a sanity check
where you check something
you already know the answer to.
Right?
So if you set beta to 0, you
get that the transformation
is an integrator, good.
If you set beta and
anything else, what happens?
Well, the pole goes
screaming out that way.
That's good, right?
Remember good is that way.
Right?
That's not always true.
But when you're trying to
make something work fast,
that's the rule.
Right?
Fast is over there.
So the idea then would be that
if I hook up this circuit--
right, I take the feedback,
run it into an op-amp
and multiply it, use that
to control the motor instead
of my turning the
knob, then this thing
should have the behavior that
the pole goes from the origin
to the right.
So the question is, if that
happened, what would happen?
OK, just doing the same kind of
analysis we did for the op-amp,
the step response
goes from being
the response of a pole, which
is an integrator, to being
this kind of a response,
which has a final value.
That converts it from
being voltage to velocity
into voltage to angle.
Does that make sense?
It used to when the feedback
was 0, the pole was at 0.
So the output continuously rose.
There was no
steady-state position.
But now with feedback,
I get a step response
that has a final value.
The effect of moving
the pole is the same
as the effect of
moving the pole.
In the op-amp example,
I get a step response
that becomes
increasingly like a step.
It goes from being a
sluggish step to a fast step.
OK, so that's the way I use
003 to use feedback to fix
the motor.
And I've done that.
So I have to move the input
to the amplifier from my pot
to the op-amp, which
is there hopefully.
So now when I turn it on,
it becomes a position.
OK, and I can test that
by turning the pot.
And in fact, when I turn
the pot, the motor moves.
Wonderful, voila, I won.
Right?
Great.
Yes, applause please.
Come on.
[APPLAUSE]
Exactly, exactly.
OK, well, it's
pretty wimpy actually
because I've got this motor
that weighs about, I don't know,
three pounds.
And it's exerting about a
quarter of an ounce of torque.
It's not really very impressive.
So how do I fix it?
What do I do?
How do I fix it?
I have a wimpy controller.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: More gain.
DENNIS FREEMAN: More
gain, of course.
So remember that response.
So now, I turn off the
motor and increase the gain
by a factor of three.
And the answer is much
better, well, maybe.
So what do I do?
More gain, of course.
So another factor of three--
much better, well, maybe.
So another factor of three.
OK, another factor of three.
Hmm, another factor of three.
Some of you close may hear that
there's a little buzzing sound
now.
I can hear it.
That's the op-amp
killing itself.
OK, it's not working.
Why is it not?
Is it working?
I just gave it away.
It's not working.
How do I know it's not working?
Here's my theory.
Here's my answer.
How do they match or mismatch?
Is it an angle controller?
Yes or no?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Didn't
we just do this?
DENNIS FREEMAN: Yeah,
it's an angle controller.
What's different about this
behavior and that behavior?
AUDIENCE: There's oscillation.
DENNIS FREEMAN:
There's oscillation.
Right, this thing,
turn it back on.
Let the thing kill itself.
There's an oscillation.
Turn the gain down so it doesn't
kill itself quite as quickly.
It's oscillating.
Watch the oscillation.
Think about characterizing
the oscillation.
Make the gain smaller.
That's bad.
Ignore that.
Think about the oscillation.
It's still oscillating.
Factor of three smaller,
it's still oscillating.
That doesn't oscillate.
What's wrong?
OK, so the $64,000 question,
what did I do wrong?
Right, the goal is to
make a model of the motor,
analyze the model, figure out
how to put feedback around it,
make it perfect.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: The model
on the board was
created without any inertia.
DENNIS FREEMAN:
I made too simple
of a model for the motor.
I ignored inertia.
I ignored all manner of things.
I ignored friction.
So how can you tell that
I ignored those things?
So one way you can tell--
let's see.
Is it off or on?
It's on.
Or turn it off.
Go back to the
original configuration
where it's a speed controller.
Turn the speed on a little bit.
Turn it off.
Grab it with my fingers.
Turn it on.
Now, release it.
What did you see?
Grab it with my fingers.
Turn it on.
Let go.
We're trying to
poke a hole in this.
There is my model.
My model is wrong.
I claim I just told you the
key experiment for figuring out
why my model is wrong.
Now you have to figure out how
to interpret that experiment.
So what does my theory say would
happen if I turn on the power,
hold the bar, and release it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: It
should instantly
reach the terminal velocity.
What's it doing?
AUDIENCE: I has just like
a rise time [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: It's ramping up.
That's what's wrong
with my model.
OK, so the model is too simple.
It's not just an integrator.
It's a slow integrator.
OK, I can model that too.
If I model the
slow integration, I
can think about the
motor doesn't really
behave like an integrator.
It works like a
sluggish integrator.
That might be a lot easier
to see if I write that in s.
So that's the same as
gamma p over s plus gamma.
No, s times-- no, close, wrong.
So it used to be gamma over s.
Now, it's gamma over s s plus p.
OK, so I'm replacing what
had been an integrator here
with a sluggish integrator.
Sluggish is another pole.
So instead of representing it
by a single pole at the origin,
I represent it by two poles.
If you calculate
the step response
for the single
pole at the origin,
you get the straight line.
That was model one.
If you calculate the step
response for the modified
model, that's this one.
Ultimately, they
become parallel.
So the speed becomes the same.
But there's sluggishness
because of inertia
and so forth so that it takes
a while for the real motor
to achieve that.
So you can see that in the model
two response, because the angle
does not immediately
change when I let go of it,
it takes a while for
it to start to change.
That's inertia.
So if I put that model, model
two, into the feedback loop,
then I make a different
prediction about the way things
should work.
That prediction is shown here.
Right?
That's just thinking
about system functions,
saying that I've got two
poles, trying to figure out
where the poles are, figuring
out where the time domain
response is, integrating it to
turn it into a step response.
Do all those things,
and you get a response.
The point is that the new
model looks like two poles.
And when you analyze
the root locus,
those poles move when
you change the feedback.
So as I change the feedback
number, beta, as beta
goes from 0 to big, the
poles go toward each other
and then split off.
That's just math.
That's the math that
was showed over here.
All I did was write the
second model up there,
figure out the system function,
find the poles of the system
function.
They depend on beta.
And that dependence
is shown here.
And so the response
then, that's where
the oscillations come from.
If the gain is big
enough, I get a pair
of poles that are
off the real axis.
The fact that they have an
imaginary component, the poles,
means that there's
an oscillation.
And what happens is I
change the feedback is not
that the oscillation goes away.
In fact, the real part of
the envelope doesn't change.
That's roughly what
I was seeing here.
If you watched what was
going on in the closed-loop
configuration, it always
oscillated for a couple
of seconds--
like a second or two
seconds or three seconds.
That second or two
seconds didn't change.
What did change was the bumps--
how many bumps there
were in the two seconds.
And that's what the theory says.
Because the real part of
the imaginary pair of poles
doesn't change, the
envelope doesn't change.
But because the imaginary
part does change,
the oscillation
frequency does change.
So the result then is something
whose envelope doesn't really
improve.
So that model then to
a large extent does
predict the behavior
that I have measured.
And then what that
motivates is if I
want to make the
motor work better,
I need some even
better controller
because my simple proportional
controller, that's
as good as it's going to do.
OK, so what I tried
to illustrate today
was ways of thinking
about feedback
to enhance performance.
We looked at an
op-amp and saw how
you could think about feedback
increasing the bandwidth
or making it faster.
We looked at a
motor and found out
how you could think about
changing the motor from being
a voltage-controlled velocity to
a voltage-controlled position.
And we saw how
the feedback could
be used for both of those.
Next time, we'll look at
a couple other examples.
Thanks.